since we've been awarded the World Cup
it has been now 12 years
and Qatar has been subject to a campaign
a systematic campaign starting from
bribing and and buying the World Cup
you know and now reaching to a level
where Qatar is called as an unfootable
Nation unfortunately what's your
personal view on the people who are
saying these things whether they be
professional footballers whether they be
politicians whether they be members of
the media why don't they just come and
see themselves and experience themselves
a preaching from a distance is not a
solution according to boycott the World
Cup or who are not coming to the World
Cup it's their decision at the end of
the day but why they would deprive the
people and the public from attending and
enjoying the World Cup so everyone is
football we should stay out of politics
of course I mean we we always say that
you know Sports should not never be
politicized what kind of message they
are sending for their own public if they
are just criticizing and preaching from
a distance what about their own problems
within their countries
which they are turning a blind eye and
now they they want you not to preach the
world outside honestly not me not the
Qatari people only but there is a lot of
people
from around the world they are seeing
this is just a sense of arrogancy
a sense of people who cannot accept a
small country in the Middle East
has one uh the bit to host the World Cup
Harry Kane the England football captain
is going to wear a one love armband he's
not the only footballer who has come out
and said that they are going to make a
stance
what do you think about that
well first of all in the purchase FIFA
was not our rules
this is this is just you know uh
International in the pitch it's sub it's
really uh for the FIFA whatever they
allow or not allow it's not what Qatar
allows or not
in the country we are welcoming
everybody
we are not discriminating anyone and
we've been saying this uh repeatingly
that everybody is welcome we would like
to invite everyone to come and to enjoy
the football and to enjoy the festivity
and the celebration
why everyone is expecting that other
discriminates someone or another all
what we are asking for we have our
cultural norms we have our society
and what they like and what they don't
like we are not going to change the
society for four weeks event yet we are
respecting everyone and expecting from
everyone to respect our laws you said to
respect qatar's cultures and lots it is
illegal to be homosexual in Qatar if
to respect our laws yes but if two men
or two women who go to the World Cup as
fans football fans hold hands in a
street
kiss in the street
what will happen to them
they're always this uh actually the rose
doesn't allow display of public
affection whether it's a man and man or
a man or woman that's that's our law
holding hands is not a display of public
uh public eviction as far as you know